any advice on removing and replacing
those people in your life who don't want
the best for you one thing you do have
to realize at some point is that
sometimes people need a wake-up call and
it's hard on them and it's hard on you
but that doesn't necessarily mean that
it's wrong for them you let people get
away with things that aren't in their
best interest they're certainly not in
your best interest you put a halt to it
you don't want to allow non-reciprocal
Behavior to continue and if you allow
that to happen around you then you're
basically saying that it's okay and it's
not okay it's not okay for you and so
it's reasonable to set limits